a well-known california pastor has had
enough
of the lockdown he is going to defy the
lockdown
and he's got a great excuse a very
clever strategy
for how he's going to do it good morning
everyone i'm so happy to welcome you to
the
grace community church peaceful protest
it's a peaceful protest we're protesting
the devil aren't we
so john mcarthur in california he's
holding services
pastor rob mccoy of god speak calvary
chapel in thousand oaks california
said just uh just day before i wish it
didn't have to come to this i really do
but we will be violating the judge's
order we will be
open this sunday meanwhile you've got
orders of the catholic church who are
sort of cleverly
getting around some of the lockdown
problems you've got
synagogues being targeted in new york
and you've got
a real question here as the secular left
the church of wokism
comes and clamps down on religious life
per se
are we going to join together or are we
going to perish apart we'll get into it
i'm michael knows this the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment
from last thursday i was going through
my michael knowles show youtube channel
comments and my favorite one is this is
actually a great point
from bpatman ben b patman
says everyone's saying that biden has
dementia
but in his defense he was this stupid 30
years ago
it's actually an appointment you know
it's just obviously insulting joe biden
but
it does make an important point it is
simply a lie
to pretend that joe biden was some
brilliant wonderful great statesman 30
years ago
and he's declined he was always a doofus
he was always a liar he was always a
plagiarist he wasn't always an empty
suit
and he remains one today he's just
lost a few steps he's lost more than a
few steps
he's showing obvious signs of cognitive
decline
and the left is going to try to blame it
on all sorts of things going back to his
childhood but it's just
not going to work and and we can go
through that point by point
it occurs to me also you might you might
notice if you're watching the show right
now i'm not in my usual studio it looks
like i'm in a lovely
sort of living room somewhere because
i'm i'm taking part in the lincoln
fellowship at the claremont
institute and you know basically you get
a bunch of conservatives to come down
for a week
and talk about kind of what conservatism
means now what
what freedom means now specifically what
religious liberty means now
and and how we can understand the
american founding with all this insanity
going on and people tearing down statues
and people burning the country and it
occurred to me
specifically on this question of
religious liberty
we've got a big fight moving forward i
played that clip earlier of john
mcarthur
i don't particularly like john macarthur
john mcarthur is probably the most
anti-catholic preacher in the entire
country
he regularly misrepresents the faith so
i don't i'm not exactly given to liking
this guy
but i like his protest i like the fact
that he is defying
this outrageous political overreach by
the left
and there are a lot of pastors doing
that a lot of protestant pastors a lot
of mainline protestant pastors a lot of
evangelical
a lot of catholic orders are working
their ways around
the the lockdowns a lot of jewish groups
are being targeted
in in new york for that matter right to
bill de blasio
you know it seems like every his
angriest tweets during the whole covet
lockdown are just to threaten jews and
say he's going to shut down
synagogues permanently what does this
mean
this is something we've been talking
about as we've been examining the
founding of this country
the founding fathers did not want an
established
church right the first amendment says
there will not be an established church
at the national level a lot of people
mistakenly took this to
to mean that this was a either a total
separation of church and state or even
worse
that our government was secular but our
govern that is just a
lie that is a total 20th century fiction
lock that away with the tooth fairy in
the easter bunny
the founders had a very sophisticated
view of religion and we are seeing
the fruit right now of not heeding their
warning but we do know what to do we'll
get to that in one second first however
i've got to thank our friends over at
ring speaking of safety
you know we've got a whole lot more
deliveries these days probably
people aren't leaving their homes as
much they're working from home they're
doing things at home
and so you're getting a lot of packages
well you want to know who's at your
front door
and you can do that either from your
bedroom or if you do happen to go to the
office or maybe you're traveling i know
a lot of people are doing that too
you can always check in on ring i
i love ring i it makes me feel good to
know that sweet little lace is a good
shot but that's not enough okay that's
not enough you also
want to be able to check in on your home
one one great thing about ring so you've
got
the all-new ring video doorbell three
means you can keep a closer eye on
things than ever before
gives you protection in every corner
smart lighting brightens up blind spots
make sure you always come home to a
brightly lit house
full home security systems give you
everything you need to protect your
family pets and property
but one of my favorite things about this
is when my friends buy a new house
i give them ring as a housewarming
present
and it makes them safe you know it looks
really cool and most importantly
it's pretty inexpensive so you see you
seem like a great guy when you're giving
this to them as a gift
get a special offer on a ring welcome
kit right now when you go to ring.com
knowles that includes the video doorbell
3 and chime pro all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today ring dot com slash knowles kenner
wlas
ring.com knowles so one thing we've been
talking about here
as we've been talking about the founding
fathers is their their view on a church
right
this is not a total separation of church
and state this is not a preference for
secularism
god forbid there's no established church
at the national level in part actually
because there were established churches
at the state level
various states had established churches
but they had different kinds of churches
and obviously there were a lot of
different religions in america
one thing we've been discussing is that
the view of the founders would have been
that at the national level
one single established religion would be
tyrannical if you've only got one right
one church at that level in the american
idea
two religions would lead inevitably to
civil war
you've got these two religions
contending against one another
not going to last very long not very
well look around around the middle east
you see two major religious groups what
happens it doesn't go great
but many religions you have peace
that's that's one way the founders
thought about religion and it seems
counterintuitive
one religion tyrannical two religions
civil war lots of religions
peace because you you're not going to
take one particular preference over
another
you're not going to you know you're
going to be so distracted with all the
different religions
however and really when we say that we
mostly mean all the different
varieties of christianity mostly
protestantism but
catholicism as well and judaism
george washington writes a famous letter
to a jewish congregation
but that's not what we have right now
what what it occurs to me we have right
now
is two broadly competing religious ideas
that is
religion and atheism secularism leftism
whatever you want to call it those are
the competing religious ideas right now
and secularism has advanced and advanced
and advanced
to the point that they're now trying to
trap us into a tiny little corner where
maybe we can have a little tiny bit of
religious liberty but that's it
and while we're all busy fighting
amongst ourselves they are going to
back us into that corner we can't have
that happen okay we we have to realize
the founders
despised atheism it was one of the worst
things you could call people there were
there were many social mores and
even laws going back all the way to the
earliest parts of the country
against atheism what we would now call
secularism
our founders talked at length about how
you need a religious people like an
actual traditionally religious people
to have a freedom to have our society
and right now those religious people are
on the brink of extinction because the
secular government is telling us we
can't even go to church anymore
without being arrested can't have that
what we need is
is some unity okay we need some
solidarity here
in the country among religious people of
all stripes may be invoking some of the
same ideas we had
at the founding of this country in many
ways we could try to
to bring back the founding ideas of this
country that's going to be the religious
battle though that's going to be the
religious crusade
and i think we're going to have to stand
together we're gonna have to
join or die as ben franklin said we're
gonna have to stand together
or we're all gonna fall fall down on our
own
speaking of misrepresenting catholicism
in particular and religion generally
the lincoln project you know the lincoln
project it's this group of democrat
advisor con men political consultants
who are basically milking democratic
small dollar donors for everything
they're worth and pretending that
they're going to
kick donald trump out of the gop or
something
a total con they just posted a tweet
on this question of religion over the
weekend they said joe biden is a devout
catholic and regularly attends sunday
service
the last time trump went to church he
gassed peaceful americans
now so a lot of problems here one
catholics don't refer to sunday service
catholics go to mass
if the lincoln project knew anything
about what they were talking about they
would know that distinction
beyond that joe biden's a devout
catholic joe biden is endorsed by
planned parenthood
joe biden was denied the eucharist the
communion
at a church not so long ago joe biden is
an apostate
from his faith who was rightly denied
the eucharist there's nothing devout
about it but you see the left all the
time
talk they pretend nancy pelosi also
actually they
they say she's also a devout catholic or
andrew cuomo andrew cuomo lit up
buildings in new york city pink
to celebrate the wholesale slaughter of
children okay not
not a catholic not christian
we cannot let them get away with this
kind of thing we need to call it out for
what it is
and some pastors and some some bishops
and some priests are doing that now
we need a lot more of that the idea had
always been this
back away from the religious questions
don't have the religious people
attack the civil authorities don't talk
about politics
and then maybe they'll leave us these
little crumbs of religious liberty
they're not doing that okay they're
suing nuns for goodness sakes they're
not going to do that
you've got to get tougher you're going
to lose the whole game
and joe but even if joe biden were a
devout catholic
which he's not but even if he were he
would not be protecting your liberty
because joe biden can't form a coherent
sentence
the trump campaign has a great new ad on
this by the way we'll get into what it
means how it's going to play politically
first though i got to thank our friends
over at wise foods you probably already
know that our sponsor company
uh wise company has changed their name
too ready-wise
now is a better time than any to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options
ready wise has things like emergency
meals free dried fruits and vegetables
for convenient on-the-go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
if the past few months have shown you
anything it's to expect the unexpected
and you will have peace of mind you'll
feel a lot better if
you stock up with ready-wise the meals
are extremely simple you just add water
they have a very long shelf life it
makes being prepared
simple and affordable you get to protect
yourself and your family you can order
online and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep this week
my listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com when entering knowles
canon wles at checkout or when you call
855-453-2945
do it right there is no risk right now
readywise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy
no risk in taking the initiative to get
yourself ready
and your family prepared today that is
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com
promo code knowles to get free shipping
head on over there right now
so even if even if joe biden did want to
protect our most cherished liberties he
probably wouldn't be able to do it
because
he more or less can only campaign
on a rhetorical platform of gibberish
take a listen to the latest
1.2 billion so you go ahead and you
stack spaghetti sauce at a store
and in a supermarket you control the guy
or the woman who runs the
run brings out the carts on on on a
forklift
what happened yeah that's gonna that's
the guy who's gonna defend all of our
liberties and
bring us back to a uh to a sophisticated
understanding of checks and balances in
the american
i don't think so i think he's ram
rambling incoherently about spaghetti
sauce
and it's not just one isolated incident
we've played many on this show the trump
campaign right now is a devastating ad
the ad doesn't include any people
openly attacking joe biden the ad is
just a comparison
of joe biden in 2008 and joe biden in
2020 don't forget
they're blaming right now the democrats
are saying oh these attacks on joe biden
it's just about his childhood stutter
he hasn't lost a step he's still totally
with it you sure about that take a
listen
you ask anybody in there whether or not
in 2008 foreign policy this
administration
has made them better off in the last
eight years
and uh and this fight in 2020.
in addition to that we have to make sure
that we uh
we are in a position that we are we can
insure every single solitary kid
2008 catastrophic health insurance right
off the bat
we can do that for the cost of the just
one thing
the tax cut for people in the top one
percent um
2020 with
i don't know you got to give them to the
people are going to spend the money
you got to deal with making sure
american companies can be competitive
they have a healthcare plan that doesn't
put them at a disadvantage when they
compete overseas
um you know there's a uh during world
war ii
uh you know where roosevelt came up with
a thing
that uh you know was totally different
than
a than the it's called he called the you
know
[Music]
what happened to joe biden that's the
only question at the end of the ad
it's undeniable i what the media like to
do now with the democrats like to do is
memory hole everything that happened
more than five minutes ago so you just
don't remember they don't show you clips
of joe biden
even in 2008 forget about 1998 1988 1978
guy's been around a long time
it's not a childhood stutter okay he's
lost a step
he's lost more than a step he's
forgetting where he is he's forgetting
what his name is
and i i trump has received some
criticism the campaign has received
criticism
for going on this line of attack
part of that is people think that we're
setting expectations too low here
as conservatives we should we should let
people see what's going on at the
debates
and and make a judgment for themselves
the trouble is the left is openly
trying not to debate and the biden
campaign is saying we want a debate but
that's bs
because all the people around the biden
campaign who are buoying up his entire
candidacy
are doing their damnedest to cancel
these debates the new york times
left-wing columnists left-wing tv show
hosts even comedy hosts even people in
the general popular culture
don't want biden on that debate stage
here's
jimmy fallon right is mainstream a kind
of center-left comedian
as you get saying oh come on already who
needs debates
speaking of the president his campaign
wants to make some changes to the debate
schedule
normally there's just three but check
out what they're proposing
the trump campaign is asking for a
fourth presidential debate to be held
in the first week of september to get
ahead of early voting
oh my god we're debating about the
debates they haven't even started i'm
already exhausted
at this point who even needs debates who
who is undecided who's tuning in like
i want to see what this donald trump
guy's all about
then i'll make my mind up i need at
least three debates
i haven't haven't figured out who i'm
going for yet then once i do after the
third debate maybe the fourth one then
oh
then i listen actually i don't mind
another debate as long as it's just
trump naming things he sees in the room
podium moderator biden camera tv
that's the last day for that joke
notice who was missing from that riff i
don't even call it a joke wasn't
particularly funny he heard some groans
out in the audience
joe biden was missing it was all about
trump the whole thing right he says is
there anyone out there who doesn't have
his mind made up about trump well what
about people who
want to make up their mind about biden
either you're not just voting against
somebody
you have a candidate the democrats don't
really have a candidate they have this
empty shell of a man who can't remember
his own name and who's an empty who's
been an empty suit from the beginning
and what they want you to to believe is
that this election is only about donald
trump but it's not elections are choices
they're binary choices in america if you
vote against donald trump that means
you're voting for joe biden does anybody
really think
joe biden can can be president is
competent
is fit to be president i never thought
he was
but he certainly isn't now i mean just
at a very practical managerial level
the man does not appear to have his wits
about him
whatever those wits were so if
if you make it about those two guys i
think trump wins
is trump's pitch for the last few days
is don't forget not last few days last
few weeks at least is
we need order we need law and order we
need some stability in this country
i'm a competent man i'm an adult i've
got my wits about me
i'm not a child and then there's joe
biden you know who's
who's kind of watching television or
something in his basement
not even campaigning not even knowing
what this campaign is about don't let
them do this to you
don't let them hide this is part of the
reason why they want to cancel the
debates is they want to keep it about
trump for as long
as possible don't let them do it because
they're going to gaslight you on it too
i kid you not i was unfortunately
watching some cnn
over the weekend i've been traveling a
little bit so you're in an airport
that's that is the time you watch cnn
and brian stelter had the audacity to
suggest on his show with a number of
guests
that the biden campaign is being treated
unfairly
because the media the mainstream media
are too
pro-trump take a listen
if you look at like the 1990s and the
way that rush limbaugh and others sort
of sharpen their teeth on bill clinton
this has been the way they've built
audiences for three decades now
yeah i don't want to claim it's new i
just i'm arguing that it's getting worse
it's getting more severe
uh aaron your view of this you know when
you see um
entire media companies essentially exist
to tear down joe biden
is there an equivalent to that on the
left tearing down trump
uh there really isn't and you know what
i would say it it's a it's really a diet
of this
type of information that a lot of these
voters are getting a lot of the voters
that i talk to i can uh you know when i
interview them i do hear
uh them saying a lot of the talking
points that sound very familiar from
from some of these shows which i try to
listen to
when i'm out on the campaign trail or
when i'm at home you know watching tv
you know you can you can hear these uh
these comments being echoed
uh by voters and you know that this is
the diet that they're on
you know am radio uh you know
conservative talk
uh also social media i mean the trump
campaign is running a full-blown
campaign on social media that is
completely
off the radar for for a lot of a lot of
uh you know regular media
is not covering this there there is a
media company dedicated to going after
joe biden is there anything like that on
the left dedicated to going after donald
trump
other than abc nbc cbs
which had over 92 negative coverage of
donald trump from the beginning
or the new york times or the washington
post or msnbc
or cnn or
or the whole media the entire
the entire mainstream media have been
hysterically anti-trump
from day one and before that they were
anti-bush and before
before that i guess they were
anti-romney then auntie mccain then
anti-bush then anti-dole
then they've been anti-republican from
the beginning especially anti-trump
they've spread ridiculous conspiracy
theories about him like that he's a
moscow spy who's uh you know a stooge
and a traitor to russia
or or they they said they didn't pay any
of his taxes it completely made up
or they said he was actually working for
ukraine
or are they colluding with them or he
all just this ridiculous
nonsense for and they say they say worse
things by the way
they talk about i mean they they suggest
that he's he's
you know a creep and a lech and of this
and of that and he's a
rapist and a this system of that i mean
they say all these sorts of terrible
things
and then they come back they say yeah
the media they're just so they're just
so against biden
listen to what they cite they say yeah
there's right wing talk radio
wait so rush limbaugh okay you've got
the entire media apparatus is pro biden
and you've got rush limbaugh he's
pro-trump basically right rush limbaugh
kind of is talk radio
then everybody else just kind of falls
within that umbrella or they say
yeah trump's making these posts on
social media
oh the campaign is using social media
are we we're still allowed to do that
please right is that okay republicans
are still allowed to
campaign on social media the biden
campaign is campaigning on social media
do they they don't mention that
so are they just liars are they
gaslighting us yeah probably they do
gaslight us
all the time because
oh my gosh not only are the the
left-wing media attacking trump and
attacking trump supporters
there are actually media watchdogs many
of whom i'm sure are watching the show
right now
who are groups like media matters or
right wing watch all these kind of
political operative organizations
that pretend to be 501c3 nonprofits that
exist just to
not only take out republican politicians
but to take out even
republican commentators people talking
about it so we've got
we've got the media attacking us and
we've got the the media
watchdogs attack you've got all these
sort of things so they're they're
gaslighting us on one hand but to give
stelter and the democrats the benefit of
the doubt
let's say they're not lying for a second
it actually
is plausible that they don't realize
that the whole media are pro
pro-biden and anti-trump and the reason
for that is the same reason that you and
i are not aware of the air that we walk
around in
and fish are not aware of the water that
they swim around
in it's the whole culture
when we talk about fake news we're not
just talking about one or two fake
stories in the new york times though
there are many fake stories in the new
york times prominent ones
it's the whole culture the thing that
makes them fake news
is that they pretend they're news
they're not news
they're not objective they're partisan
hacks
who pretend to be news and get certain
benefits for that
but who are merely operatives
mouthpieces for
the democratic party and now
specifically for joe biden
the candidate we're i think a lot of
people on the left are not aware of that
so it is possible that they're that
oblivious
they might just be lying to us too maybe
it's a little bit of both and maybe
that's
what we're going to see more of through
through november you know we
i think even we even we conservatives
even people who
take a listen to this show who listen to
the various examples of this
sometimes forget how crazy the culture
has gotten
and then we and then we get reminded
university of georgia has just
issued a mandate to students some
guidance on how to move forward during
covid
do you think the guidance was on how
they can continue to learn how they can
take notes how they can
go to class while protecting themselves
that no
the guidance was about how when these
teenagers have
sex they should wear masks when they
have sex
it's not a joke here's the guidance
consider wearing a face mask during sex
heavy breathing and panting can further
spread the virus and wearing a mask
can reduce the risk so
i mean that's all true i get i guess
that's right
but do you remember when when
universities were
in loco parentis when they were when you
know they would kick the girls out of
the dorms at
9 00 pm or actually before that when
education was single sex
because you were discouraged from having
sex in the culture broadly outside of
marriage
and certainly at universities with all
these now
the the university is giving you tips on
how to get kinky with the co-eds
they're encouraging you to do it and
then but that's kind of you know
perfectly natural you might say then the
next part is even
even wilder they say quote you are your
safest
sex partner practice solo sex
or limit the number of sexual partners
you have so
so limit the numbers like hey they can't
tell you
to uh you know maybe cool it and keep
your modesty and virtue because that
they call that [ __ ] shaving so they say
would you mind maybe limiting
the number of sexual partners you know
no more than three or four a day please
and
please practice solo saying what is solo
sex
so i i believe woody allen defined it as
sex with someone who loves you when it's
just you
and you know you turn the blinds down
and you go into your own room
in any case that's a real inversion of
the culture
for the vast majority of the history of
this country
sex outside of marriage would be
discouraged sex among teenagers who are
off at
college would be discouraged
masturbation would be discouraged
but we now have a new a new kind of
religious
worldview a new morality and we pretend
that it's
just the absence of religion we pretend
that it's totally neutral but it's not
there's nothing neutral about
encouraging teenagers to have sex with
one another there's nothing neutral
about encouraging masturbation with kind
of
silly euphemisms and things like that
that that is another religious
that's the religious view of the secular
left and we're
we are coming to a head in this
religious war cardinal manning i mention
the quote on the show all the time
because it's so true
at bottom all human conflict is
theological
and those are two theologies those are
two
religious views of the world which one
do you want to live in
one is very tempting you know uh all
this kind of indulgent behavior is
very fun there's a there's a reason that
it's so tempting
but is is that what's going to make a
good society is that what's going to
make us good
good people as individuals or are we
going to come to regret that
you know it's always fun to have a lot
of drinks at the time it's always fun
you know okay i'll have one more you
know five drinks later
but then you have the hangover the next
day we've got a bit of a cultural
hangover right now
and going back reading those founding
fathers you notice there's a big
difference they make between
liberty and licentiousness liberty we're
exercising your freedom
in the true sense of that raising
ourselves up leading to human
flourishing
and licentiousness which is outright
just discouraged or banned or
talked about as sort of the the end of
free government
licentiousness where you just follow
your own appetites do whatever you want
well now we've got
a culture that i it seems to me that the
christian culture that that founded this
country
promoted liberty and ordered liberty and
this current religion of secular wokism
is promoting nothing other than
licentiousness you want to see how
creepy this gets
hasbro they make toys hasbro
just made a new toy called the trolls
world tour giggle and sing
poppy this is a doll that that
you know you push a butt like all these
little toys right you push a button it
makes a sound
so where's the button well it's this
little troll girl
obviously like a child and she's got a
button on her stomach and you push the
button on her stomach and she makes a
sound
she's got another button they put
another button
in between her legs and when you push
that button
she makes she makes disturbing sound the
button itself is disturbingly placed
and the sound she makes are disturbing
too take a listen to one parent who
bought this toy
and discovered this creepy pervy button
so i just touched her tummy and she's
going to sing for a minute
but down here is a button right here
on her privates and if you push those
she makes these sounds
oh yeah like a gasping sound
that is yucky
that is yucky and creepy and weird
it's so funny you you hear about all
these conspiracy theories that always
float around the internet of
international pedophile rings and this
pedophile culture right and then
if you'll say oh that's like a crazy
conspiracy theory
and and you know no there's no way that
there's this international pedophile
ring that involves heads of state and
prime ministers and members of the royal
family and they go to a caribbean island
and say oh wait a second yeah
yikes right and then now forget about
that and
it's hard for me to imagine that that
was an accident with that toy doll
i'm not uh saying there's some some
group somewhere some conspiracy group of
like the illuminati you know
who's making all these kind of weird
pedophile things but it is evidence of a
of a
broken sexual culture that anyone at any
point
would think that that is acceptable to
have a little button
in on the doll right there where you
push it and
and the doll makes those sounds and then
kids are gonna get those
that is some creepy creepy stuff
and it it it makes you understand that
this debate we're having right now
on the left and the right it comes down
to a kind of cultural and religious
point we used to just debate over tax
rates that was kind of 80s 90s
conservatism
it's like yeah we're going to lower
taxes a lot more
yeah well if you elect us again we'll
lower taxes even more and i like low
taxes but that's not motivating people
there's a cultural and religious issue
gives you a lot of a lot of respect for
the young kids who are a little bit more
traditional who are saying something
here
seriously broken we'll get into that
we'll get into specifically by the way
what president trump is going to do for
the next three months
not just as a matter of campaign but as
a matter of policy there was a huge
announcement
that he made uh just over the past few
days we'll get to all that but first
i've got to say thank you to you i'm
gonna thank you for heading on over
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel that's where we
we check through the comments and pick
pick comments that you know sort of
tickle us
like we're a troll doll um so head on
over there subscribe we appreciate it
i've got a full interview with eric
mataxis that uh
we did right before i came down down
here uh
last week so great great interview eric
is just fascinating
you can go check that out also don't
forget to join our most exclusive
membership tier over at daily wire all
access all access members get to join
all access
live which is a ton of fun all access
live
is you know when we just speak directly
with uh with the members and it's great
and you know we make a lot of
friendships that way
also you you will get uh early access
and exclusive access to some promos that
we're doing for instance we just made
this baseball the daily wire baseball
bat it was very cool it's only available
to all access members
sold out within less than 48 hours i'm
sorry to say even before i got mine
but uh make sure you sign up now you'll
you'll have access to that you'll also
get uh not one but two leftist years
tumblr so right now head to
dailywire.com
noel's get 20 off all access with coupon
code access
that's 20 off with coupon code access
dailywire.com
knowles and we'll be right back with a
lot more
when you see creepy things like that
troll doll it it starts to give you a
little bit
more of an understanding of these 18
year old
traditionalist kids who are anti-porn do
you remember at the end of
last year it was december january we
were having this debate on the right
over whether to ban
porn or to regulate porn and you know
some people said we got to ban it
outright
and some people were aghast they said oh
my gosh no
porn is a blessing of liberty we love
porn born so
george washington would roll over in his
grave if you ban porn
and you might say it's impractical to
ban porn but
as a matter of principle i don't think
any of the founders would have had a
problem with that
makes you understand them because you
look at this completely insane broken
sexual culture
where you've got you've got university
administrators whose job it is
to encourage teenagers to to fornicate
and masturbate and they're sending out
guidelines about this and toy makers who
are making
pervert child sex dolls you don't want
to live in that culture do you
and one line you always heard in that in
that whole porn debate was
that these more traditionalist kids who
were overwhelmingly young teenagers or
early 20s
that they were hypocrites because you
know what i bet some of them have looked
at porn before i bet some of them have
looked at naked ladies on the internet
see they're hypocrites we don't need to
listen to them
that's not hypocrisy the fact that we
live
in this highly pornographic culture
where we move around it like we move
through the air or fish move through the
water
maybe that's a reason why these
especially these young kids
are so anti-porn because they've lived
with it they know
not only the temptation of it but they
know the awful effects of it
awful effects on young men awful effects
on young women
you know it causes men to have sexual
problems it's
led to an increase in in
bizarre sex sometimes violent sex
completely disordered sexual
expectations obviously lots of sexual
regret which is what's
led to what's called the the ep you know
the epidemic of campus rape
you know what we hear now is that one in
four women will be raped on campus as
though harvard yard is as dangerous as
downtown fallujah
that's not exactly what's going on here
right i can't i can't imagine that's
true i don't see evidence of that what's
really going on though is we have this
insanely
broken sexual culture and so people are
very confused and have different
expectations
and lots and lots of shame and regret
the fact that some of these 18 year old
kids you know if you're 18
right now you never grew you grew up in
a world that
always had high-speed internet and this
kind of ubiquitous porn all this stuff
maybe maybe that informs your opinion
maybe maybe these kids have lived
through and they say yeah this is bad
we shouldn't we shouldn't have so much
of this we should not encourage this
we are we are learning from the children
out of the mouths of babes i suppose
meanwhile you see child childish temper
tantrums all around the country
people burning down the country tearing
down statues screaming shrieking
and president trump just made an
explicit appeal on this point
he was giving a press conference and
he was describing the green new deal
this is a left-wing policy they've been
pushing for it now for a few years
massive would totally overhaul society
has very little to do with the
environment the natural environment has
much more to do with socialism
and the redistribution of wealth and
reparations for slavery and all this
kind of nonsense
and he came and he said you know the
green new deal is for children
and i'm the adult in the room
you look at what they want to do they
want to raise everybody's taxes
everybody and they want to do the green
new deal which will decimate our
country and decimate it's ridiculous too
it's childish
i actually say the green new deal is
childish
it's for children it's not for adults
anybody that believes in that is uh
i don't know maybe it's politics i don't
even think it's good politics they seem
to think so we'll see how they do
is it good politics i don't think it is
for the left i think i think this is an
important theme that
that since the trump campaign has kind
of righted the ship they've been picking
up on which is
law and order right we are going to
restore law and order
the last few months have been an insane
temper tantrum trump is the adult in the
room and he's going to take charge
and i think that's a successful message
for the trump campaign
and he's taking it not just on making
fun of the green new deal he's putting
forward affirmative policies so we've
been waiting for another covid relief
package remember the last one spent
two to three trillion levered up to six
trillion and it got us through
four months sort of didn't even really
do that we're kind of hobbling away in
the economy as in freefall
so the senate can't agree with the house
on a deal and the house democrats can't
agree with the senate republicans
so trump just came out issued executive
orders on covid relief
and the plan includes some
some good policy some bad policy take a
listen to the announcement
democrats are obstructing all of it
therefore i'm
taking executive action we've had it
and we're going to save american jobs
and provide relief to the american
workers that i'll be signing
these bills in a very short period of
time
first one is on providing a payroll tax
holiday
to americans earning less than one
hundred thousand dollars per year in a
few
moments i will sign a directive
instructing the treasury department
to allow employers to defer payment
of the employee portion of certain
payroll taxes
from september 1st and we're actually
going to be making that we just got
the word we're just getting some
word from a lot of people we didn't
think we'd have to do this because we
thought the
democrats would be reasonable but
they've been not
only unreasonable they've been
ridiculous
they have been ridiculous payroll tax
holiday is a great idea a lot of
republicans have been calling for that
the thing that's nice about it is it
gives
workers some money because you pay part
of your payroll tax but it also gives
employers an incentive to hire you back
because it gives the employers a little
bit of a cut they pay part of the
payroll tax so it makes perfect sense
it's a great idea
love that policy i love that trump did
it also
some of trump's executive order is going
to protect renters from evictions
so obviously puts puts people who own
property
in a tough position but what are you
going to do you're going to evict people
they haven't done it yet so i don't know
that you had to issue
a guidance on that and then expands
unemployment benefits by 400
per week 25 of which could be covered by
the states i like the idea that the
states have to cover some of it because
they've been clamoring for this
i don't like the idea that you're
incentivizing people to
stay out of work and that's really what
this is doing if you pay people more
money than they would ordinarily get
paid
to work to not work what are people
going to do they're going to not work
there was a cato study that showed that
a full
two-thirds of people on the covet
unemployment benefits have made more
money than they
otherwise would have made working and a
full one-third of people
made double and not a good situation
i don't beat grudge people their extra
400 bucks a week or whatever the deal
600 bucks a week before this
but you're you're playing into the
democratic hands
of giving people a reason not to go back
to work i think
trump wants to seem like daddy warbucks
here he wants to seem like santa claus
and like he really cares about the
people and he's not beholden to old
libertarian
stodgy ideologies fine i see all of that
but
you've got what now 80 some odd days
until the election you've got
to incentivize people to go back to work
you you know you keep paying out 400 per
week that's not going to do a whole lot
it took us what it was six trillion
dollars total to get us through four
months that's 18 trillion dollars a year
if we were to just keep
trying to stimulate the economy all the
way through kovid
well at the rate that gdp is falling we
won't even have 18 trillion dollars even
if we took everybody's money
can't do that gato got to just push to
reopen and
by the way the american people would be
on trump's side there's a video that
went viral over the weekend
of a bunch of good old-fashioned
patriots
who were who were at a pro-police rally
and a bunch of antifa thugs organized
leftist
vandals came up and started harassing
not just a regular ordinary protester
but a guy in a wheelchair it did not end
very well for antifa
you you communist scum
and these antifa guys are all wearing
black they're in full right they're
an organized oh
here we go
ah there goes the brawl oh my
oh my and it unfortunately turns violent
these antifa people had weapons on them
by the way
and so they they're coming out they're
harassing this guy in the wheelchair
initially they're just being chased out
of town then it seems to turn into a
brawl
finally finally the cops get there and
the antifa people start throwing punches
at the cops which
is just not not a good idea anti for
people
this is this we were talking about porn
earlier that is porn to the american
people
watching a bunch of patriots not take it
from
violent leftist thugs and then watching
then those violent leftless thugs get
arrested
that is like porn that is a crack for
the american people
because no matter what stupid nonsense
you see on the mainstream media
which pretends that the media are
left-wing and they lament out
how or they pretend that the media are
right-wing rather and they lament how
there's no left-wing media even as
they're on cnn
no matter what they say the american
people are normal
mostly normal they like their liberty
they like their cherished traditions
they don't like it when leftist thugs
harass people in wheelchairs they don't
like that
okay it does show you a lesson that
first of all if the cops are not going
to enforce order if the civil authority
is not going to enforce order
then civilians are going to do it and we
don't like vigilante justice in this
country
but someone someone will impose order
who's that going to be i don't think
antifa is turning out very well
for the the left i don't think blm
trained marxists are working very well
for the left actually the mayor of
portland ted wheeler
completely derelicted his duty he's let
that that city go up in flames
but he recently did an interview and he
said stop it stop being so violent
you're giving the trump campaign the ads
that they want
this is a political point so it's a
little out of field
um don't think for a moment that you are
if you are participating in this
activity
that you are not being a prop
for the re-election campaign of donald
trump
because you absolutely are you are
creating
the b-roll film that will be used in ads
nationally
to help donald trump during his campaign
you don't want to be part of that then
don't show up
uh that's true but i don't really
understand why mayor wheeler thinks that
it's illegitimate
for the right to just film the left
doing what they do
you know oh you're playing into the
nefarious hands of the trump campaign
by letting them film you doing what you
do
it's not like the trump campaign is
making this stuff up they're just
turning on the cameras
and letting it play out this kind of
violence in the streets that you notice
it's not about one issue or another
right it's not they're not doing this
over covet or something
the the heads of blms they were trained
marxists
what is marxism marxism is
the most widespread pernicious
atheist ideology dedicated to the
overthrow of western civilization that
we have ever seen
that's what it is and we fought a whole
cold war against it
seems like we haven't totally beaten it
out these issues are not just at the
political level
they're not even just at the cultural
level like cardinal manning says they
get down to a
religious level as well
you're either uh you're either on the
right side or the wrong side you're with
the angels or you're with the devils
you're with me or against me to quote
scripture
which side are you on we can all sit
around
i notice this with conservatives
conservatives always like to sit around
and and
you know you could get a room of 100
conservatives and all every single one
of them would would be a different kind
of conservative
and all they would want to do is argue
about which kind of conservative they
are and you'd have the libertarians
yelling at the traditionalists and
all this kind of stuff hostilities are
never so hot
as when they are within a religion
intra-religious
debates are always much hotter than
inter religious debate
and i i bring up religion here too
because it's not just about the politics
it's about
it's about the religion i think we are
going to have to band together
as people who broadly support
our cherished traditions our
institutions our rights
our liberties our culture our
forefathers and ultimately our god
we're going to have to band together and
get past
all of our differences because there is
a
cold religious civil war going on right
now between
religion and the secular left and
not religion and when you read those
founders whose statues the left is
toppling down right now
they all feared that this day would come
and they knew that the republic could
not withstand it
that is the choice in the election and
there is a choice it's not just all
about trump or president trump's
personality and ironically president
trump who
the left always calls so childish he may
be the adult in the room right now
that's that's the evidence that we're
seeing right that's that's what the
trump campaign is making
so which side are you on are we going to
come together
are we going to are we going to join
together like ben franklin said or
are we going to perish apart that's our
show i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knull show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
you